Celia: And then as part of their stories they
of course went to town on, "Chris is just
lying there, she looks like a sleeping
beauty, her long fair hair fanned out
over the pillow her eyes closed
her chest her bre- her beautiful
breasts gently up and down with the
breathing machine". And you go okay, no,
she's probably seated in a wheelchair
because they have to drain the lungs and
they sit them up in wheelchairs, secondly
she's in a vegetative state that means
she has a sleep wake of cycle so as much
as you and I have our eyes open, she has
her eyes open, C - she doesn't look like
a sleeping beauty she has spasticity so
after six years or however long it was
that we had her being in this stage she
would have twisted limbs, so instead of
the cross-questioning about what do you
think somebody in a vegetative state looks
like "wrong! wrong! wrong!", I go, go on then
finish his story about something a
vegetative state, and you answer all my
questions about what you think somebody
in a vegetative state is like and you get
it wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong, but
I've got in writing now, and I've got it
in as in the shape of a story.
Matt: Celia Kitzinger is one of my academic
icons.
She was the PhD supervisor of my old
supervisor, so maybe I feel there's a bit
of academic ancestry there. But I really
feel a lot of my thinking, my approach to
research, and even the methods I adopt
have been in part formed by her work. She
was one of the first to talk about
social constructionism in relation to
what was known as lesbian and gay
psychology in the 1980s, now more
commonly referred to as LGBT psychology
and was a leading developer of discourse
and conversation analytic approaches in
relation to the study of gender and
sexuality. But for me what sets it apart
is her staunch activism and commitment
to human rights.
Celia went to the High Court to get an
overseas marriage with her wife,
Professor Sue Wilkinson, legally
recognized, which finally came about with
the same-sex marriage act 2013. More
recently she co-founded the Coma and
Disorders of Consciousness Research
Center, after her sister Polly was
catastrophically brain injured in a car
accident, and this research in
collaboration with her sister Professor
Jenny Kitzinger focuses particularly on
the socio-legal issues surrounding the
treatment of people in
and minimally conscious states. I met
with Celia in July to discuss her work.
After pioneering a social
constructionist approach with her PhD
the social construction of lesbianism, I
was particularly interested in how she
now thinks about epistemology in
relation to her current research
interests. Celia: I think this place for just
not worrying about epistemology and
getting on with doing your interviews
and listening to what people are saying
and treating them not as true but as
good enough to be treated as true
because that's where what you've got
so I've done with Jenny I've done I
think it's close to 100 now interviews
with family members of people in
vegetative and minerally conscious
states saying tell tell me what happened
and they start with the cycling accident
or the stroke and they tell me what the
person looked like when they first saw
them in intensive care and they tell me
what happened when they were moved to
high dependency and they described the
eye-opening moment and they talk about
the awfulness of the lung infections and
their hope for recovery and their hope
gradually fading, they talk about the
nurses who cared and gave fantastic
loving care they talk about the nurses
who didn't care and they talk about the
physiotherapy and the splints to
straighten their limbs and the horror of
the tilt table which is like a sort of
crucifixion thing that you tilt somebody
up right on, they talk about the smart
testing they talk about whether they
agree or disagree with the doctor's
diagnosis. You know what, I'm not very
interested in whether right that's
essentialist or social constructionist, I
largely report it as this is what people
said, and frankly, I know people will
forgotten certain things and in moments
of high emotion have misunderstood or
misremembered others but here's what
here's what they experience, and I pretty,
we pretty much present that as evidence
of what families go through, and
the value of that is you take that data
to the medical profession and to the
lawyers and you say "This is what
families experience" okay so you didn't
know that families experience it this
way we're telling you.
And for sure they sometimes say, "I'm sure
it didn't happen that way because uh
because doctors wouldn't have done that
because" or "that doesn't make sense, that
medical procedure he's describing can't
have been done like that" yeah, okay, so
yeah that, not everything in interviews is
going to be right but there's enough, and
again it it's about cumulation of the
same things over and over, so this
accumulation of families saying for
example. "they they said he would be
disabled, but I had no idea what they
meant by that, I thought you'd been a
wheelchair or something this is not
disability, this is, this is devastation"
and we get versions of that in over and
over and over a we're in interviews that
doctors somehow are failing to
communicate to families in the early
days what the outcome of that kind of
brain injury will be. Well I'm really
frankly not very interested in whether
that's his social constructionist or you
know how that, the fact is if lots of
families say that to us and I take the
fact that lots of families say that to
us to doctors, doctors start thinking
"we're not explaining this very well, we
should try harder what would work better?"
How, how can we communicate to families
the level of devastation that this kind
of brain injury brings, without seeming
to, you know, terrify them and and and
make claims that can't be supported on
the one hand if the patient does
actually recover, but you know how do you
communicate that level of disability, and
that's a helpful discussion and that
actually moves things forward and that
helps families. So, stuff all the epistemo-
that's why I'm inpatient with, what
exactly is the epistemological status of
that data, its value is in communicating
to doctors you need to do this job
better. And, and it works to do that it
does work to do that so that's really
important, but, having said that so that's
the, I don't mind doing positivist
interviewing now it works. There's the
issue of how you translate what you find
in your data, into something that
communicates with people in a way that
an academic journal article doesn't.
So one of the things that I'm interested
in, and have worked with Jenny on, is
translating research findings, and they
are all qualitative actually, into
stories that can be told to audiences
who can engage with them at a different
kind of level, from from the academic
article or a summary of an academic
article, or an "easy read" version of an
academic article, or an academic talk, so
we've done puppet shows, shadow
puppets, so we got a puppet show person
to- these were actually from our
interviews, so our interviews were audio
recorded like this one is being, with permission to use the audio, and
to the sound of clips of audio, we have the
shadow puppets, we have Icarus falling
out of the sky and bumping his head
rather hard
we have Icarus being taken in an
ambulance that's what this is all
shadows a shadow ambulance
"doo-doo doo-doo" to a hospital, we have
Icarus in bed with a bandaged head we
have relatives visiting and leaning over
and the whole thing's takes 20 minutes
and it was a professional shadow artist
who created the show based on our
Matt: Based on the audio. Celia: based on our audio
recordings and our analysis of them so
we'd written the analysis of them
already of what sort of trajectory of
families is like, and then we had
permission for her to use some of the
audio so we selected out the audio to go
with it, and so she's created a
20-minute show which you sit in a
darkened room and she puts it on and we
have a discussion period of up to an
hour afterwards, and we've shown that in
care homes, hospitals, rehab centers to
families and practicing clinicians as
well, and it's a way of conveying, so I
think that's innovative
I think that's managing to convey
qualitative data in new ways. We've also
done the health talk thing which you
may have seen which is clips video clips
from our interviews, online, so families
can sit at home and look at them and we've
used those in training and education,
we've got sonnets, I don't know if you've
seen those? Matt: No. Celia: We commissioned a poet James Nash he's a quite well-known
northern poet, to write some sonnets for
us, and he's done three sonnets about
brain injury and recovery or death
following brain injury, which, which we
got some funding to set to music
so there's films of him reading them and
and set to music and, and sort of nice
background trees and leaves and flowers
and things, we've done, we've asked
families to write their own messages to
doctors, social workers, lawyers
themselves, the patient, anyone, on
postcards, so we've got a postcard exhibition
which we display, when we're giving talks
just literally, just families written
postcards for things like you know "We
are her family listen to us, trust us, you
don't know her, we do" that sort of thing
Umm, yeah and Jenny's done this
radio program of between the ears which
is soundscapes associated with brain
injuries all of those are ways of taking
what we know about brain injury, which
comes directly from our research, and
translating it into forms of,
communicating, I don't know
the emotional truth of it and, the
the lived reality of it, yeah the lived
reality stuff discourses! The lived reality
of it in a way that people who are
making decisions either clinical or
judicial, can engage with in a different
kind of way. So I think that's where I
think the innovation is needed it's less
in arguing about the details of
particular research methods, and more in
thinking about if we want these, if we
want our findings to have an effect in
the world how do we communicate those to
people. Matt: With this adoption of creative
ways of communicating qualitative
research, I wondered whether Celia had
ever had trouble in having it recognized
as 'academic' However she explained to me
that with the university's emphasis on
'impact', she'd actually found quite the
opposite. Celia: One of the great,
amazingly wonderful things
my academic career is most of my career,
the political work that I did the policy
to related work that I did was
considered not part of my academic
existence it was in fact slightly grubby
hands, you know, my job was to produce
research and it was up to the rest of
the world to decide whether it was
interesting and whether they wanted to
use it for anything, but I was, it was
pure ivory tower stuff when I started so
the fact that I was involved in first in
lesbian and gay politics, and now in
policy change around brain injury has
just been, oh and same-sex marriage
stuff, when I was doing that the
university issued a statement saying
that they they understood that I was
involved in same-sex marriage act-, a
legal same-sex marriage case and that
they wished it to be known that "they did
not support it nor did they oppose it
they were entirely neutral". So it-
during my academic lifetime that has so
shifted from being, disreputable evening
a weekend stuff, we know you do it but
this is not part of your academic work,
towards it being impact, and something
you send off to the Ref, and obviously
I'm an impact case study for this
department, and that has been wholly
positive from my point of view it has
not changed what I do, at all, I still do
what I do, in the way that I want to do
it, the only way in which it has changed
what I do is think give me money to do
it so that kind of that kind of
encourages me and gives me more scope to
do what I want to do. so for me the
impact agenda has been wonderful
Matt: Often I think about the concept of impact as
being abstract and unobtainable, but I
was challenged by Celia, as impact just
seems to be a natural byproduct of her
work. I was interested in how Celia
demonstrates this impact. Celia: Basically we we
don't spend a lot of time capturing
impact it's more it's more that we spend
a lot of time doing the things that we
think will create change in the world in
the way that we think change needs to be
created and then we see the changes
happening like we get, like we give a talk
in a care home about
the fact that treatment best interest
decisions need to be made about feeding
tubes and this care home has never made a best
interest decision about a feeding tube
and then four weeks later they phone up
and say they've made some best
interest decisions and will we come and
talk to the families, so you know that or
we say that we think something called
Practice Direction 9E which is part of
the quarter protection practice
directions is wrong we write a
document that it's wrong we tell some
lawyers and solicitors and judges that
we think it's wrong, I got invited to
talk to do some continuing professional
development training with judges and
yesterday I was at a meeting at which
they were going to shall we shall we
abolish Practice Direction 9E, this
doesn't seem right, so you know I'll be
able to point to first there was
Practice Direction 9E which I thought
was wrong, I said it was wrong, and now
there isn't it isn't there anymore, so I
wasn't the only person who was saying it
was wrong, but I was one of them, and those
sorts of things make a difference, I mean the bigger
question is how do you make a difference
in the world ,and can you prove it was
just you, no you can't prove it was
just you, can you show cause and effect, I
pressed this button and this thing went
bing! Nope, but you can show that you were
part of how social change works in a
sociological sense which is multiple
different forces coming to bear on
trying to create a change. Matt: Over 20 years
ago Celia wrote a paper with an
undergraduate student using the story
completion method, which has influenced a
lot of qualitative researchers, including
myself, to use the method. You can hear
about how Celia has used story completion
for research around disorders of
consciousness below, and you can also
hear a short clip at the beginning of
the interview, but I was interested in
hearing generally what celia now thinks
about the story completion method.
I think it's a fun method, I'm actually amazed
that something I do with an
undergraduate student to satisfy an
intellectual itch basically, I was just
sort of scratching away at a question
what happens if you take data and you
don't interpret it the way that story
completion has regularly been used and
you do it a different way, it's amazing!
That something two decades ago with an
undergraduate should have been seen as
fundamental to a- and it was an old
method then, I'm a dying method then,
what is all this new excitement about
story completion? I'm slightly bemused!
Actually, to answer my own question,
I think partly it points to the poverty
of methods that we have as qualitative
researchers. Matt: Ok talk a bit about what do mean by poverty of methods.
Celia: Well there haven't been any radical new
innovative methods that I know of
actually when I was doing um Q
methodology for my PhD,
Personal Construct Theory was like "oh we're all
getting excited about Personal Construct Theory
that seems to completely died, I think
it's fundamentally unsatisfactory to
collect qualitative data, because there
are too many ways in which we know that
we're not getting it I don't know what
to call it
the truth about the world, and we know
we're not allowed to think that there's
a truth about the world either,
so we're uncertain about what we're
doing... We all know that none of the
methods that we use are perfect for
finding out what's happening in the
world let alone for putting the world to
rights, so I think we're all fairly
desperate to think perhaps this method
perhaps that method, that method, let's
find a new one, and I think I've been
around long enough to see people looking
for different new ones, and sometimes
finding old ones, and trying to reinvent
them to meet today's contingencies
and that's fine, but in the end it leaves me
thinking I'll just stick with, I'll just
stick with interviews!
Matt: Really? Because I- in my head
you're characterised by let's step away
from interviews. Celia: See I've been doing
nothing but interviews for the last
three years! Matt: But it's this this
return to, because the way you-
I suppose with disorders of
consciousness is sort of natural, but it
is it is almost giving voice...
Celia: Giving voice yes! Matt: but which is a-a
problematic, I mean you're not blindly
you're not kind of objectively giving
voice to people
but has your... Celia: They say I am, they
say, you know, that's fantastic you you're
bearing witness to what we're going
through, bearing witness and giving voice
are phrases that are quite often used and
I feel proud to hear that I am bearing
witness and giving voice and those are
phrases that I precisely used in that
article I did with Sue Wilkinson called
validating women's voices which was a
methodological critique of exactly that
perspective, so... Matt: so it's not a problematic
concept for you giving voice? Celia: It's
problematic in all sorts of ways, I want
people to have their own voices I don't
want to give somebody else a voice I
don't want that to be a world in which
that's necessary
not to mention the fact that if you
filter your voice through mine it's
gonna get distorted on the way out, to a
greater or lesser degree
I'm not epistemologically naive about
that and I know about the power dynamics
that are involved in attempting to
enable other people to speak through you
through one's own writing and speech,
it's one of the reasons I think that we
wanted to put the filmed interviews on a
website and as part of the purpose of
the shadow artistry, because that's
actually people's own voices
it's literally their breath coming out
and their sound, but even so we've
selected it we've shaped it we've
decided on the order as much, as you do
when you put quotes in an in a in an
article, although it is literally their
voice, it's you know, five minutes from a
two-hour interview, so yeah um, and we do
get a lot of pub- what you call it,
participant validation you go back to
the participant to say you know we've
y'know we had families with brain injuries on
all of our steering groups and advisory
panels and, and of course we are a family
with somebody with a brain injury
although our experience is not
everyone's experience, but these, these
arguments get rehearsed and rehearsed and rehearsed
these, these are concerns that can
paralyse you, you can, you can end up
just worrying about politics and theory
and epistemology and not do anything
because there isn't an answer, at least not one
I've found in 30 more, 30-plus years of
doing research, so... I've forgot what the question was
Matt: Well do people get bogged- because
you wrote about how you stopped using Q methodology
because people focused more on the method than
the topic. Celia: Yes Matt: So, do you think that uhh
yeah it can detract from the findings
when you use these... Celia: Yeah I mean
one of the nice things about interviews
is virtually everything that can be said
about interviews has been said, we're
running out arguments about them, so we have
very little discussion about our research
methodology now that we're
using interviews, whereas with with Q
methodology it was endless and tedious
with focus groups, see Jenny, Jenny used
to be a really big user of focus groups
and is quite well known for as a focus
group researcher, she's done a couple of
books on focus groups she was
instrumental in, she wrote a very famous
massively cited article on focus groups
for sensitive topics because people said
you couldn't do focus groups on
sensitive topics and she was researching
things that hiv/aids and child sexual
abuse and things with prisoners and she
was going yes you can, look... We're not
using focus groups, so we b- we both
actually have written an awful lot on
methodology, because we sort of
thought somehow somewhere there would be
the right way or a better way or a
valuable way of doing it, and I guess the
driving burning ambition now is how can
how... there is a problem with the world
these people's rights are being abused.
How can I find out
why that's happening and how can I
challenge it and put it right, and that
that overrides everything else and
actually just asking people tell me
what's happening, is... and hearing what
they say and treating it in a
non-ironical way
while bearing in mind that's just one
version... and reporting here's
what they say, it just seems like a
simple way of doing what I want to do
which is stop human rights abuses, of
these very vulnerable patients and their
families. Matt: So that's it! Hope our chat has
given you some things to think about and
I'm looking forward to seeing your
thoughts and comments.